fabrice kebour ou alors il vous manque
plus quizy 2013
les amis aujourd'hui nous allons faire
une vidéo comme on les faisait en 2013
et ce qu'était la comprendront pourquoi
je dis ça à l'époque sur youtube dans le
gaming avec deux écoles y avait l'école
call of duty et l'école des jeux indé et
soins les genres dépendance c'était des
jeux d'horreur parce que c'était un peu
les plus simples à faire et c'était
surtout ceux qui faisaient plus qui fait
des gens aujourd'hui on va jouer à un
jeu d'horreur vraiment très beau comme à
l'époque on va faire semblant que le jeu
génial même s'il n'est pas génial on est
sur celui qui aime à de croustilles
crabes
on sait qu'ils ont regardé bob l'eponge
vous allez kiffer bref au nom
l'interface elle fait tellement pas
rêver on est bel et bien en 2013 quand
tu peux choisir la qualité des
graphismes sur la le menu du jeu c'est
très grave ok c'est parti on joue
monsieur crabes c'est tout ce que je
sais c'est matic c'est trop bien aux
[ __ ] c'est la pince de monsieur crap
0 on va faire genre que tout est ouf
comme en 2013 vraiment ok donc là il a
juste à [ __ ] ça sent qwerty le jeu
comme en 2013 alors chose à faire
rassembler l'argent qu'il ya dans la
caisse et dans tout le bureau rassembler
les derniers krabi baptise chez qui les
poubelles dans la salle de bain au cas
où il reste quelques euros fermé le
restaurant et partir ok un gros méchant
nous rend visite
quand les lumières clignotent va être
cachés permanemment je me cache où je me
cachais aux comptes closing balkanique
de fils d'or is the long way to escape
impac est donc le seul moyen de lui
échapper ces deux barricades et le
bureau lachance zone cei fait et je fais
quoi ensuite il faut que je rassemble
l'argent qu'il ya dans la caisse ok
alors on va être dans la caisse c'est ça
la caisse oui aussi long elle rassemble
le vide se plaît monsieur crabe fait
très très vite raconté euros très vite
fait ça aussi vite qu'ils avaient de
lafarge dont sera archi bien se plaît à
l'est
non vous servez chaud c'est moi qui vous
ai fait peur je suis désolé je suis le
screamer en fait dans cette vidéo c'est
incroyable qu'un mais ironie sa spatule
ce petit ont reculé tu n'auras pas un
centime de mon restaurant well well well
chrischona de ce côté là à shrek faut
rassembler les burgers oui c'est ça on
est pas trop les packs totalement c'est
super long franchement monsieur même
temps j'avoue il a des pinces à la place
des mains mais imagine toi ferté macé
avec des pinces et pas des mains c'est
choquant même nom mais vrai j'ai pas eu
peur dray comme en 2013 qu'il faut faire
après abba faut qu'on prenne l'argent
qu'à la [ __ ] je n'ai pas calé ça j'ai
l'habitude alors nettement après chaque
opus est ce que je fais je ramasse comme
ça l'argent et afrique et dans la salle
de bain à mon avis il faut passer par là
avant la regarder en toute logique et
faire quoi faute chic et quoi j'ai pas
compris à deux voire à o'keefe au tuc et
la poubelle à les fouilles mais que sait
pas s'ils n'ont vraiment dans une
poubelle quand je t'assure qu'il ya deux
serviettes tu trouve facilement leur
aussi en a tous les objectifs sont
complétés trouve la clé dans le big man
et barre toi c'est quoi déjà le buzz
semaine on a dit vous avez comme en 2013
il faut su réagir c'est important c'est
l'élément crucial d'une vidéo 2013
[ __ ] bon à temps il faut tout
recommencer au nom et on rassemble les
burgers et on ramasse l'argent de la
caisse
et on observe la grande qualité
graphique de ce jeu et on récupère les
oraux dans la poubelle et on est enfin
au même point que tu as l'air à l'iphone
parce qu il faut qu'on trouve il a dit
trouve dans le big man tu sais quoi
[ __ ] oh non je vais vraiment faire ça
regardez c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer
regardez ce qui est en train de se
[Applaudissements]
excusez-moi fait remettre des effets
2013 un peu dans cette vidéo alors il
est où le sous sol à tominian trappler
quelque chose me dit que ça mène au
sous-sol la clé est quelque part dans le
sous sol
tu doit la trouver en bas tient du tour
c'est vrai que ça rajoute un peu de
minutes de gameplay je me cache ou du
coup quand ça clignote
non mais là je suis à l'abri entre deux
cas ce mec ok on y retourne chez paquet
christie crabb ilya vingt sol aussi
grand mais cambrai son loyer doit être
hyper élevé c'est pour ça que c'est une
grosse pince en plus est un crabe qui
possèdent de grosses pinces du coup
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas facile
moi je fais le même mais c'est en train
de m'énerver à fond ça m'énerve vraiment
ne pas trouver la clé de mon père dans
ce sol si mal fait si bien fait pardon
non mais c'est génial mais je vient
d'apparaître
[Applaudissements]
adapté d'un gros en fait vu que le jeu
est simple il a tout misé sur ce moment
là quoi c'est pour pouvoir dire derrière
moi mon jeu c'est une amie de gameplay
sa manche caché caché
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] j'ai oublié qu'en 2013 je
m'amusais pas dans mes vidéos
[Musique]
la clé mois ben en fait compte par le
manque d'argent c'est bien comment je me
casse
j'ai la clé quand je me cache à la
caméra s'est éteinte comme en 2013
à l'aller avec tient pas bien pas bien
pas où je vous jure qu'on va y arriver
c'est incroyable l'échelle est là oui on
s'en va battre pour verrouiller le
restaurant et partir avec nos euros sur
un paradis fiscal pour gagner encore
plus
attends je me permets d'en mourir de
faim le pauvre moi je m'en bats les
couilles apm systématique
oh non il nous suit
bon escoussans fait un petit deuxième la
com en 2013 mais là on est bien là
j'aurais dû me raser à blanc et me
laisser pousser les cheveux nous sommes
sur do you copie un jeu 100 fois mieux
que suffisamment non vraiment en gros on
joue un garde forestier qui doit aider
un gars asri un chemin à travers la
forêt et je trouve ça stylet comme
concept et personne n'y a joué avant moi
regarder personne faut que j'allume ma
tour voilà accident tout seul le switch
est cassée il faut le maintenir pour que
ça reste allumée ça marche
du coup comme daf on voit enfin quand
personne tu appelles ça marche
oui on est là on est là on est en train
de filer à regarder les étoiles entre
potes et toi monsieur vous avez beaucoup
trop de tâches c'est dans le sens calme
et voué au [ __ ] il fait chier on était
bien là oui tu sais bien soit mais me
parle pas mal aussi là mais il en fait
des caisses comme en 2013
ok j allume les lumières over aller il
va arrêter de pleurer l'aérien qui
poursuit monga a par sa rupture avec son
ex au ça fait mal à l'eau
et ben voilà pourquoi t'es pas besoin de
malmö parlé hier je te fais même des
petits clignotement foyer où est-ce
qu'on peut le voir moi j'aimerais bien
qu'on puisse le voir le gars au moment
juste pour le pointer du doigt comme ça
à faire ok la carte car nationaux
actuels auxquels il doit être ici il
faut qu'il aille tout droit ok donc ils
prennent le chemin de gauche à rien mais
mme banon non non vraiment pas qui a
parlé de fils de [ __ ] et l'eau tu peux
répéter à temps annoncé une feuille on
est là bas il est là-bas gros continue
son chemin et est bientôt là si tu
m'écoutes il est génial il parle comme
un corbeau hockey attend faut je regarde
la carte bouge pas bouge pas bouge pas
donc lui il doit être vert là il ya la
mine qui est là à neuf qui coûtent une
long du lac pas le long de la mine ok
bon allez on va lui mettre un peu de
light pour qu il se repère
[Applaudissements]
bon ok c'est stylé le principe du jeu il
est vraiment bien je trouve le délire de
tête d'un mec et tu le vois traverser la
forêt et essaie de le guider c'est
vraiment cool tu es juste peur de la fin
parce que j'ai vraiment vu beaucoup de
gens se plaindre de la faim et moi quand
même fait un nul j'ai tendance à
maltraiter mhs donc j'ai pas envie de la
péter quoi
tabernacle dostie bon en tout cas en
héros dans le tour il est en bas dans
l'humidité la terre et les tic donc on
craint rien ah j'ai compris j'ai compris
les skyzos il croit qu'un truc qu'ils
traquent et tout mais c'est juste lui
qui est un peu baiser voilà c'était
lucas le psychologue et si on analyse
approfondie de l'homme de la forêt a
alors voilà un groupe qui prennent à
droite à la prochaine si tu racontes
gros mairie de paniquer y a rien dans la
forêt à part des loups qui ont très faim
des ours qui veulent te [ __ ] d'éthique
qui peuvent se transmettre la maladie de
lyme rien d'autre c'est qu'on aimerait
comme taf
non mais en vrai ça existe vraiment
stuff jetant pas du chien je parle de
métier ça existe
o o alors là cette blague là c'était
comme en 2013 c'est insupportable je
n'ai pensé très fort
[Musique]
ok ok ok bouge pas bouge pas bouge pas
bouge pas normand je lui ai dit de
prendre ce chemin là qu perry doit être
là a mis cet impair nounours ah oui
l'eau ces bonnes chances mais qu'est ce
que je dise oui non en fait les amis
c'est la fin de cette vidéo comme on
faisait en 2013 soit ça vous a plu en
vrai je vais vous dire la vérité j'ai
passé un très bon moment c'était
vraiment marrant de jouer à des petits
jeux indé comme on faisait à l'époque
comme ça faudrait peut-être qu'on fait
ça plus souvent finalement n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo si elle vous a plu et si
vous étiez en 2016
allez trêve de bavardage vous fait des
gros bisous et à très vite sur youtube
[Musique]
parra
parent
[Musique]